[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN WICKE: Thank
you for coming.
I'm Martin Wicke.
I'll speak about effective
TensorFlow for non-experts.
I'll later introduce
Francois, who will take
the second half of the talk.
So TensorFlow, why?
So I have a son.
You'll see him later
in the talk, actually.
And when I used to explain to
him how image search works,
I would have to say something
like, oh, he has a computer.
It looks at the
metadata and then looks
where the images are.
And now, when I explain how
this works, I can just say,
well, the computer
looks at the images.
And if you search for,
say, cherry blossom,
it looks at the images,
all of them in the world.
And whenever it sees one that
has cherry blossoms in it,
it returns it.
That's a much better story.
And you've seen a lot of this
at this particular event.
AI is now going
to be everywhere,
and machine learning
is everywhere.
And it generates these
products that were
impossible to imagine before.
And what makes these
products work in reality
is, for us, at
least, TensorFlow.
And this enables us
to make these apps
and make these products
that use machine learning.
And once you've written
one of these models, one
of these machine learning
systems in TensorFlow,
you can deploy it
anywhere in mobile.
TensorFlow is truly what
enables apps that tell
hot dogs from not hot dogs.
So why don't we see that more?
Why are hotdog, not hotdog
apps so cutting edge?
The main reason is
complexity, and complexities
in various shapes.
So first of all, complexity
is computational complexity.
Computational complexity
used to be a big thing.
And now, with cloud and
with all the availability
of data centers
that you can rent,
that's really not much
of an excuse anymore.
So we've kind of
solved this problem,
assuming your code can
run in a data center.
But you also have
to contend with you
have to make your code,
your models, your apps,
work on all these
different platforms.
In order to train them
in the data center,
you need to work
on CPUs, on GPUs.
You probably have
heard by now we
have this thing called a TPU.
It should work there too
because that's going to be fast.
And of course, if you want to
deploy it once you're done,
it needs to work
on a mobile device.
If you're into IoT
or embedded systems,
it has to work there too,
say, on the Raspberry
Pi or something like that.
So making that happen is hard.
And finally, machine
learning itself
is actually fairly complex.
So that's why we
have TensorFlow.
And TensorFlow gives you
distribution out of the box so
that you can run it in the
cloud if you need to do that.
It works on all of the
hardware you need to work on.
And it's fast and it's flexible.
And what I'm going
to tell you today
is that it's also super
easy to get started.
And that's why we're here.
So TensorFlow takes all the
details of a distributed system
[INAUDIBLE] hardware and
just hides them from you,
takes care of them.
You don't have to know
about it necessarily.
It's nice if you do, but if you
don't, that's not a problem.
What you mostly see
is the front end.
And what I'm going to talk about
today is the Python front end.
The generic thing that
people used to say, oh, this
is TensorFlow, it's
pretty low level.
So you're thinking about like
multiplying matrices, adding
vectors together,
that kind of thing.
What we built on top
of that is libraries
that help you do more
complex things easier.
We built a library of layers
to help you build models,
and Francois is going
to talk more about that.
We built training
infrastructure that
helps you actually train a
model and evaluate a model
and put it in production.
And again, this you
can do with Keras
or you can do with estimators.
And Francois is going
to talk about Keras.
And finally, we built
models in a box.
And those are really full,
complete machine learning
algorithms such as
run, and all you
have to do is
instantiate one and go.
That's mostly what I'm
going to talk about today.
So usually when
you talk about, oh,
my first model in TensorFlow,
it's usually something simple,
like let's fit a line to a
bunch of points or something
like that.
But nobody is actually
interested in fitting a line
to a bunch of
points, distributed.
It doesn't really happen
all that much in reality.
So we're not going to do that.
I'm going to show
you instead how
to handle a variety of features,
and then train and evaluate
different types of models,
possibly distributed.
And we do that on a data set
of cars because we have that.
I have uploaded all
the code I'm going
to show you to this address,
which has both an O and a 0,
so be a little bit careful.
And what I've done there,
it'll work with TensorFlow 1.2.
And I am not sure whether it's
been announced previously,
but there is now TensorFlow 1.2,
the first release candidate.
So my code will work with
that and nothing earlier.
So you have to watch out.
All right, so the
first model today
will be about predicting
the price of a car
from a bunch of features
about the car, information
about the car.
So without anything
more, let's just do code.
The rest of the talk's
going to code, mostly.
This is it.
This is my model
definition in TensorFlow.
I'm exaggerating
only a little bit
because this only takes into
account three different things.
So first, here we
defined the input.
And I'm defining three different
what we call feature columns.
I'm telling the model that it
should expect an input that
is a categorical
feature, a string, that's
called make in the input.
And I'm going to transform
this into something
that's usable by my
machine learning algorithm
by hashing it.
So I declare it this way,
declarative way of telling you
what to do with a
feature for the inputs.
The next thing is
I'm going to say, oh,
there's something
called horsepower,
and that's just a number.
So I call a numeric column.
And then there is
something called
cylinders, num of
cylinders in the input.
And that's also a string,
but it has very few values.
So I'm just going to
give you all the values
directly here in the code.
So in this data set,
it actually is the case
that num of cylinders is
encoded as the words "two,"
"three," "four," "six,"
and "eight," I think.
So that's it's.
So there's probably
many more of these.
But in principle,
that's what you do.
And you say, OK, this is
what my input looks like.
And then we specify what kind
of machine learning algorithm
we want to apply to this.
And in my case here,
I'm going to use
first a linear aggressor, which
is kind of the simplest way
to learn something.
And all I have to do
is tell him, hey, look,
you're going to use
these input features
that I've just declared.
That's it, and then I'm done.
Now, I still have to
give it some input data.
And TensorFlow has
off-the-shelf input pipeline
for most formats,
or for many formats.
And particularly,
here in this example,
I'm using input from pandas.
So I don't know
who knows pandas.
It's a Python library.
It can read a bunch of
stuff, process data.
It's nice.
So I'm going to read input
from a pandas data frame.
And really what
I'm telling it here
is I want to use
the batches of 64.
So each iteration
of the algorithm
will use 64 input data pieces.
I'm going to shuffle the input,
which is always a good thing
to do when you're training.
Please always shuffle the input.
And num_epochs=None means cycle
through the data indefinitely.
If you're done with the
data, just do it again.
And then I can say, OK, train me
my thing for 10,000 steps, say.
And what happens then
is that TensorFlow
goes off and trains my thing.
This is what the log
output looks like, and not
actually any interesting
information for it.
What's more interesting is that
TensorFlow will also integrate
with other tools that we have.
In particular, it will
integrate with something
called TensorBoard.
TensorBoard is this
wonderful front end
that the training
system writes data for,
and then you can visualize
it and you can look into it.
And one of the things that you
can see and what I show here
is what's called the loss curve.
Loss curve is kind of
the most important thing
to look at if you're
trying to train a model.
And what do you see here
is that our loss, that
is, kind of the error
that the model makes
when looking at data,
is decreasing over time.
And that means it's learning
something, plain and simple.
So good, that's good.
The model is learning
something, great.
The next thing I can
do with TensorBoard
is I can actually look at
the model that was created
and look at the lower
levels of the model, look
at what we call the graph.
TensorFlow works by
generating a graph,
and then this graph is shipped
to all of the distributed
workers that it has,
and it's executed there.
You don't have to worry
about this too much,
but it's awfully useful to
be able to inspect this graph
when you're doing debugging
or something like that.
So here is the graph
that was generated
by the model declaration
that I showed earlier.
And I've highlighted
in red here the part
that's the actual model.
That's the actual linear model.
And I can look inside of it.
And you can see that there are
these slightly yellow boxes.
And those are the input
processing computations
that happen in this model.
So creating all of this
is taken care of you
by the infrastructure,
but it's really useful
to be able to look at it if
you're debugging something
or if you just want
to know what happens.
OK, so what's going on?
The linear regressor I defined
is what we call an estimator.
We inherited that "estimator"
word from [INAUDIBLE].
And it's kind of this
very, very similar concept.
It supports all the
basic operations
that you need for an ML model.
You can train it.
You can evaluate it,
usually on separate data.
If you take away
anything from this talk
is that you should always
evaluate your models
on separate data
while you're training
or during your training.
You can query the
model for predictions
once you've trained it.
And then this is fancy.
You can export what
we call a saved model
and give it to
TensorFlow Serving.
There's a talk about
TensorFlow Serving tomorrow
in the amphitheater at 1:30,
and you should all go to it.
So these methods all hide
a lot of tricky details
that you don't have to worry
about and that are just done.
You can just call them, and
you can be reasonably certain
that it actually works.
We also defined an
input function earlier,
and that basically
reads from data files
and feeds data in an appropriate
format into the estimator
itself.
There's a trick here.
The estimator actually
saves its state
to what's called a checkpoint.
The checkpoint contains
all of the variables
that the model contains.
And every time we call
one of these functions,
it'll synchronize
with the checkpoint.
And this is very important
for the distributed setting
where you have several
machines and they all
do their own thing.
But they have to
synchronize, and they
synchronize when
something restarts
or when something breaks.
They synchronize via checkpoint.
The checkpoint is also what we
use to export the save model.
OK, so it's great.
So I've shown you how to train a
linear model with pandas input.
But what if you want
something else, just anything
else, really?
Well, so all of these components
are obviously swappable.
So for instance,
the pandas input
function you can swap for
other input functions.
And we have several
that are just there.
It's also pretty easy
to write your own.
So you can read from numpy.
You can read from
any Python generator.
Anything you could spit out
of a generator, you can use.
So this makes it
very, very flexible.
And you can write your
own input function too.
It's not that hard.
Also, the models
that we have are not
limited to just linear models.
So we have linear
regressor classifier.
We have a deep neural
network, which is basically
a straightforward
neural network,
basic feedforward
neural network.
And then we also
have estimators that
do random forest, KMeans,
support vector machines,
you name it.
So all of this is
available directly for use.
So you don't have to
implement it yourself.
Let's say we want
to swap this out.
So first of all, we have to
obviously change the name
of the class that we're using.
And then we'll also have to
adapt the inputs to something
that this new model can use.
So in this case,
a DNN model can't
use these categorical
features directly.
We have to do something to it.
And the two things that you can
do to a categorical feature,
typically, to make it work
with a deep neural network
is you either embed
it or you transform it
to what's called a
one-hot or an indicator.
So we do this by
simply saying, hey,
out of a make, make
me an embedding,
and out of the cylinders,
make it an indicator column
because there's not
so many values there.
Usually this is fairly
complicated stuff,
and you have to
write a lot of code.
But this is it.
All you have to do
is declare, hey, I
want an embedding for
this, and you're done.
Then also, most of these
more complicated models
have hyperparameters.
And in this case, the
DNN, basically we tell it,
hey, make me a
three-layer neural network
with layer sizes 50, 30, and 10.
And that's all really you need
to-- this is a very high level
interface.
For other models that can
be more complicated or less,
depending.
And if none of that's
worked for you,
you can still take advantage
of the training loops
and all of the
infrastructure that
is in the estimator itself,
and you can completely swap out
the model and write your own.
And the way you do this is we
have this estimator base class,
and you can put in what's
called a model function.
And this allows you
maximum flexibility.
The model function
takes the inputs,
and it produces tensors that
contain the thing that you have
to do for training,
the thing that you
have to do for evaluation.
It returns the predictions.
And then it will also produce
a save model if you need one.
So you can write
all of this yourself
if you really want to if none
of the preexisting models
fit for your use case.
And you can use
any kind of-- you
can use regular TensorFlow to
define this model function,
or you can use Keras.
And Francois will say a
little bit about that.
OK, so the exciting
thing about TensorFlow
is actually the fact
that it runs not only
in a single machine, but
distributed in a data center.
So to make this work,
we have a utility
that uses several workers
and basically trains
the model on all of
these workers at once.
We call the a
distributed training run,
like a single run of training
a model, an experiment.
And to make one
of those, we first
make an estimator, as
you've seen before.
And then we add the input
function and the estimator
together and make an experiment.
The name "experiment" comes
from hyperparameter tuning.
And I don't know
how many of you are
familiar with
hyperparameter tuning.
It's a very important
concept in machine learning.
Basically, instead
of just training
a single model
for your data, you
train a whole class of models
and you pick the best one.
And it's very powerful.
And I'm not going to go
into details on this,
but the infrastructure
for it is all set up.
So in the experiment function
that makes the experiment,
you can pass in hyperparameters.
And then you can use
those hyperparameters
to create your estimator.
And then you return that
estimator with the experiment.
And that way, you can implement
hyperparameter turning.
Well, finally, this function
that makes an experiment we
pass through what we call
the learn runner, which
just runs it.
And we can pass some user
options in a run config.
And what the run
config also does,
it contains information about
the cluster that we run it on.
And so we can use
that information.
For instance, if we
make the estimator
and we want to
tweak it depending
on how many machines
we have available
or something like
that, we can do that.
So it contains information on
how many workers do we have,
how many parameter servers
do we have, and so on.
But the run config
also takes information
from the environment,
and so we don't
have to pass it explicitly.
So what do we have
to do in order
to declare to TensorFlow,
hey, here's a cluster,
please use the whole
cluster, is we write
what's called the cluster spec.
And this is a very,
very simple thing.
It's just simply a map from
names of different machine
types that we want to
do different things,
and then a list of
all the machines
that can do this thing.
And usually, you have
Parameter Service or PS,
and you have workers.
And the parameter services
store the variables.
The workers do the actual work.
That's kind of traditional.
And you just fill out these
lists, and you're done.
And you save that.
You dump that into
the second thing here.
You dump that into an
environment variable,
and then everything else
will work from there.
OK, setting up a cluster
depends on the environment,
and I'm not going to
talk in detail about it.
But if you are
interested, it's on GitHub
in the ecosystem repo.
There's a number of scripts,
a number of examples
that help you get started.
So one thing I'd
like to mention--
and I don't know how many of
you have seen the TPU talks.
This is a pod of TPUs.
If you stick to these
concepts, your code
will basically work on a
TPU without modifications.
So you will be able to use
this once you can use it.
So I've shown you we
have, in TensorFlow,
implementations of complete
machine learning models.
You can get started with
them extremely quickly.
They come with all
of the integrations,
with TensorBoard, visualization
for serving and production,
for different hardware,
different use cases.
They obviously work in
distributed settings.
We use them in data centers.
You can use them on your
home computer network
if that's what you'd like.
You can use them in
flocks of mobile devices.
Everything is possible.
And they run on all kinds
of different hardware.
And particularly,
they will run on TPU.
It's nice.
They also always run on
GPU, on CPU, obviously.
OK, so before we move
on, the full code,
again, is at this URL.
If you're interested in more,
do check out the tutorials
on tensorflow.org,
and particularly
the estimator tutorial.
I think that may be
the most convenient
for people who want to
write their own estimators.
And then do go to
the talk tomorrow
at 1:30 in the amphitheater for
TensorFlow Serving with Noah.
And with that,
thank you very much,
and I'll hand it over to
Francois to tell you more.
[APPLAUSE]
FRANCOIS CHOLLET:
Thank you, Martin.
So [INAUDIBLE] estimators
are great for many use cases.
But what if you need
something that's
not available as a
[INAUDIBLE] estimator?
What if you need to write
your own custom model?
That's where the
Keras API comes in.
The Keras API is
this high-level API
for building TensorFlow models.
And you can use it
together with the estimator
class and the experiment
class that Martin introduced.
As you know, TensorFlow
features this fairly
low-level programming
interface where
you spend most of
your time multiplying
matrices and vectors.
And that's very powerful,
but that's also not
ideal for building very
advanced complex models.
So we really believe
that in the future,
deep learning will be part of
the toolbox of every developer,
not just machine
learning experts,
because everyone needs
intelligent applications.
And to make these
future possible,
we need to make deep
learning really easy to use.
We need to make available tools
that are accessible to anyone
because you shouldn't need
to be an expert in order
to start leveraging deep
learning to solve big problems.
So if you could design a
deep learning interface
without any constraints, what
would an ideal interface look
like?
I really think that
the core building
blocks of deep learning are
all fairly well understood.
And rather than letting the
user re-implement everything
themselves, instead,
it should be
really easy to just take
existing building blocks
and be able to quickly assemble
them to build new deep learning
data-processing pipelines.
It should be basically
like playing [INAUDIBLE].
And I think actually, if
you think about LEGO bricks,
it's the ideal metaphor.
LEGO bricks are very
intuitive to use.
They're very easy to use.
They provide this very flexible,
expressive framework in which
you can build almost anything.
They allow you to try
different things very quickly
and immediately get visual
tactile feedback about what
works and what doesn't work.
And of course, LEGO bricks
are very accessible.
They're accessible to any human
being ages five and above.
And that's really
the idea, the ideal,
I would say, that we had in mind
when we designed the Keras API.
We wanted to be the
LEGO for deep learning.
So let's take a look
at what Keras can do.
So first of all, I
think it's better
to think about Keras not
as a code base, a API
framework, or a library.
It's really just a
high-level API specification.
And it's a spec that has several
different implementations.
The main one, of course, is
the TensorFlow implementation.
But there's also an
implementation for Theano.
There's one for MXNet.
There's one for Java, and
there are more coming.
And what makes Keras different
from every other deep learning
interface that's available
is its deep focus
on user experience.
Keras is all about
making your life easier,
simplifying your
workflow, especially
in terms of providing
easy-to-use building
blocks, intuitive inferences,
in terms of providing
good feedback when things
go wrong, and in general,
just reducing complexity,
reducing cognitive load.
And of course, if you make
deep learning easier to use,
then you're also making it
accessible to more people.
So the end goal with Keras is
to make deep learning accessible
to as many people as possible.
Until now, the
TensorFlow implementation
for the Keras API
was available as part
of an external open
source repository.
But now what's
happening is that we
are bringing the
Keras API directly
into TensorFlow project.
And we are doing that to
make Keras work seamlessly
with your existing
TensorFlow workflow.
Concurrently,
what's happening is
Keras becomes available as a
new module inside TensorFlow,
the tf.keras module.
And it contains the
entire Keras API.
So if you're a TensorFlow
user, what that
means for you is that
now you get access
to this new set of easy-to-use
deep learning building blocks
that will work seamlessly
with your workflow.
And if you are an existing Keras
user, what this integration
means for you is that
suddenly, you gain access
to high-level TensorFlow
training features, things
like distributed
training, things
hyperparameter optimization,
training on Cloud ML.
So that's very powerful.
So to give you a concrete sense
of what your workflow will
be like when using the Keras
API to define your models
and when using TensorFlow
estimators and TensorFlow
experiments to train your
models in a distributed setting,
I will walk you through a simple
yet fairly advanced example.
We'll look at a video-question
answering problem.
So that's what the
problem looks like.
We have this data set of
a few thousand videos.
Each video is about
10 seconds long.
It shows some people
doing some activities.
And a deep learning
model will be
looking at the frames
of these videos,
and it will try to
make sense of it.
And then you can ask the
model short, natural language
questions about the
contents of the video.
So in this example,
we have a short video
of a man packing some
boxes into a car.
And you can ask, what
is the man doing?
And model will be
looking at the video,
will be looking at
the question, and will
have to select
one-answer word out
of a set of possible answers.
So here in this example, you
can ask, what is the man doing?
He's packing.
And that's actually an
interesting question
because if you were to
just look at a single frame
from this video, you
couldn't answer the question.
The man could be
unpacking as well.
So the reason you
know he's packing
is because of the
order of the frames.
So we expect our model
to be able to leverage
not just the visual
contents of the frames,
but the order of
the frames as well.
So needless to say, this is a
tremendously difficult problem.
Just three or four
years ago, before Keras,
before TensorFlow, this
would have been only doable
for a handful of pretty
well-funded research labs.
This would have been pretty
much a six-month project
for a team of expert engineers.
And what we are
doing now is that we
are making this really
advanced problem
accessible to pretty much anyone
with basic Python scripting
abilities.
So we are democratizing
deep learning.
So that's what our
solution looks like.
That's our network.
It is structured in three parts.
So first, you have one branch
that takes the video input
and turns it into a vector
that encodes information
about the video.
And you have one branch
that takes the question
and turns it into a vector.
So now you can
concatenate the question
vector and the video
vector, and you
can add a classifier on top.
And the job of the
classifier will
be to select the
correct answer out
of a pool of current answers.
So the first step is
to turn the video input
tensor into a vector.
A video is just a
sequence of frames.
And a frame is an image.
So what you do with an
image is that you run it
through a convnet.
That's what you do with an
image, a natural thing to do,
a CNN.
And each CNN will extract
one vector representation
for each frame.
So what you get out of that
is a sequence of vectors
encoding the frames.
And when you have a sequence,
what you do with it,
the natural thing
to do is to run it
through this sequence-processing
module called an LSTM.
And this LSTM will reduce the
sequence to a single vector.
And this vector is
encoding information
about all the frames
and their order,
so the entire visual
contents of the video.
The next thing to do
is a similar process
applied to the question.
The question is a
sequence of words.
And you will use
an embedding module
to map each word into a
vector, a word vector.
So you get a sequence
of word vectors
and reduce it using a
different LSTM layer.
Once you have your vector
rendition for your video
and your vector rendition
for your question,
you can connect them.
And you add this classifier
on top, whose job
is to select the right answer.
So that's really the
magic of deep learning.
You take these very
complex inputs,
which could be videos,
images, language, sound,
and you turn them into vectors.
So you turn them into points
in some geometric space.
You turn meaning into
points in a geometric space.
That's the essence
of deep learning.
And what's really powerful
about it is that once
you've done that, you
can use linear algebra
to make sense of these
geometric spaces.
And you can learn
interesting mappings
between different
geometric spaces.
So in our case, we
are learning a mapping
between an initial space
of videos and questions
and a space of answer words.
And we are doing that
just through exposure
to trained data.
And the way we are
doing this is really
by assembling together
these specialized blocks
for information processing.
It's a very natural thing to do.
If you have an
image, you process
it using an image-processing
module, which is CNN.
If you have a
sequence, you process
it using a sequence-processing
model, which is an LSTM.
And if you want to
select one element out
of a pool of
possible candidates,
then you use a classifier.
It's a natural thing to do.
So what you are really
doing with deep learning
is plugging together these
information-processing
bricks are pretty
similar to LEGO blocks,
right, to LEGO bricks.
So building deep learning
models is conceptually
similar to playing with LEGOs.
And if the ideas behind
deep learning are so simple,
then the implementation
should be simple as well.
So let's take a look
at the implementation.
This figure is a very
straightforward translation
of our model into a
Keras implementation.
On the video-encoding side, we
have this InceptionV3 convnet,
and we use a
time-distributed layer
to essentially apply this
convnet to each frame
alongside the time axis
of an input video tensor.
And then we pipe the output
through this LSTM layer,
which will reduce it
to a single vector.
So one interesting
thing to note here
is that our InceptionV3
convnet will come loaded
with pre-trained weights.
And the reason
that's important is
because with our
current video data set,
we don't have
enough data to learn
interesting visual
features on our own.
So we need to
leverage preexisting
visual features that were
learned on a larger data.
So imagine that in this case.
Now, that's a very common
pattern in deep learning.
And it's a pattern that is
made really easy by Keras.
And we'll see how in a second.
On the question-encoding
side, it's even simpler.
You just run the
sequence of words
into an embedding layer to
produce sequence of vectors,
and then you reduce
this sequence of vectors
to a single vector
using an LSTM layer.
So once you have this video
vector and this question
vector, you will get an item
with a simple concat up.
And you add the
classifier on top,
which is just two
dense layers which
will select the correct answer.
Let's look at the code.
So this is the
entirety of the code
for the video-encoding part.
It's just a few lines.
It's very readable.
It's very simple.
You start by
specifying your inputs.
So this is your video input.
It's a sequence of
viable number of frames.
So the None here is
the number of frames.
It's undefined,
which means it could
change from batch to batch.
And each frame is a 150
by 150 image restricted
to current channels.
In the next step,
in just one line,
we're defining an entire
InceptionV3 model,
which is fairly complex model
defined in just one line.
And it comes loaded
with pre-trained weights
from the image in a data set.
And all of this is built in.
It's already into Keras.
So you don't have
to do anything more.
It's literally just one line.
And we are not
including the top layers
because they are
not relevant to us.
And we are adding
some pooling on top,
which allows us to
extract exactly one
vector from each frame.
In the next step, we are
setting these convnet
to be non-trainable, which means
that its representations will
not be updated during training.
And the reason
that's important is
because this convnet
has already comes
with good, interesting
representations,
and you don't want
to alter them.
Again, so that's a very common
pattern in deep learning,
to take a pre-trained model
and freeze it, and make
it part of a new pipeline.
And it's a pattern that's
made really easy in Keras.
So once we have this
frozen pre-trained convnet,
we use a time-distributed
layer to distribute the convnet
across the time axis
of the video input.
And the result of that
will be this tensor
of frames which will run
through an LSTM layer
to get a single
vector for the video.
On the question side,
things are even simpler.
We define a question input
as a sequence of integers,
a viable number of integers.
So why integers?
Because every integer
will be mapped
to a vector in some vocabulary.
And we will run this
sequence of integers
into an embedding
layer, which will map
every integer to one vector.
And these embeddings
are trained, of course.
It's just part of the
weights of your model.
And then you run this sequence
of vectors through an LSTM
to reduce it to a single vector.
So
One interesting thing to note
here with the two LSTM layers
that you've
instantiated so far is
that we were not configuring the
layers beyond just specifying
the number of output units.
And that's interesting
because usually when
you're using LSTM
layers, there are
lots of things you have to keep
in mind, lots of best practices
you should be following
to make things work.
For instance, you
should remember
that the [INAUDIBLE]
weights should be
initialized with [INAUDIBLE].
You need to remember that
the [INAUDIBLE] should
be initialized to
1, and many more.
And here, we are not doing
this because all these best
practices are already
part of the default
configuration of Keras layers.
It's a very important
principle Keras,
that best practices come
included as default.
And what this means for you is
that your models will typically
just work out of
the box without you
having to tune every
parameter to make it work.
So that really ties
into our goal with Keras
to reduce cognitive load,
to reduce complexity.
We don't want you to care
about these technical details.
We just take care
of them for you.
So once you've done
encoding your video
and encoding your question,
you just use a concat up
to turn them into
a single vector,
and you add these
two dense layers
on top, which will select
one answer word out
of a vocabulary of a given size.
In the next step, you're using
your inputs and your outputs
to instantiate a Keras
model, which is essentially
a container for a
graph of layers.
And then you are specifying
the training configuration.
So you are specifying
the optimizer
that you want to use,
the AdamOptimizer.
And you are specifying
the loss function
for which you are optimizing.
So that's very simple so far.
At this stage, we have
defined our model.
We've defined our
training configuration.
And now, we want to train
this in a distributed setting,
maybe on Cloud ML.
So let's see how that works.
This is where the magic happens.
You can use the TensorFlow
estimator and experiment
classes that Martin introduced
to train this Keras model,
in a distributed setting in
just a few lines of code.
All you have to do is to
write this experiment function
in which you define
your model, you
use your model to instantiate
an estimator using
this built-in
get_estimator method.
And once you have
this estimator,
you use this to
create an experiment.
And that's where you specify
your input data, for instance.
So it's just a
few lines of code.
It's really like magic.
In just a few lines--
a very readable,
straightforward Python code--
we've defined a
state-of-the-art model,
and we are training it
in a distributed setting.
So to solve this really
challenging problem
of video-question
answering, which
would have been completely out
of reach to almost anyone just
a few years ago.
So these APIs, these
new high-level APIs,
are really democratizing
deep learning.
And that's made
possible by two things.
On the one hand, you
have the Keras API,
which is this very high-level,
easy-to-use and powerful way
to define deep planning
models in TensorFlow.
And besides being
just easy to use,
each layer comes with good
default configurations,
which allows your
model to just run out
of the box without
much training.
And the other piece of magic is
these new high-level TensorFlow
training APIs that Martin
introduced, estimator
and experiment.
And together, this allows you to
solve any deep learning problem
with very little effort.
So we think these new APIs are
a big step towards democratizing
deep learning and
making TensorFlow
and deep learning
available to everyone.
And we hope you will
find them useful.
And we are very
much looking forward
to seeing all the
cool applications
that we'll be building
with TensorFlow and Keras.
Thank you very
much for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]